what's up my fellow geeks talking about
the marvel legends series tesseract from
the loki series no not infinity war not
end game but
loki and it comes with a loki figurine
because
yeah it's pretty much a cube that lights
up in it and apparently at the back
you can see that the cube
opens up to
show the uh the stones one of the
infinity stones and the box says that it
has lighting effects
[Music]
inside the box
a bunch of manuals here the manual
maybe there's some instructions involved
so the batteries will be placed in the
infinity stone itself okay we got this
white box here this is a usbc cable no i
don't think so oh okay so this is the
loki figurine
yes
oh a bit rickety the flame to the sword
and then attach it
to his hand big green rice looks pretty
good so it's pretty darn good let
him stand there
toss this away
now to
the
well
let's go you see
that's how the packaging works
and
it's the cube
no
dc power adapter or anything it's all
battery powered comes in a very nice
shell
uh transparent acrylic case i would say
top lid
comes out slide it out
taking this apart
step aside here okay basically
splits in two
like so and you have a giant
fairly stone which houses all the uh led
lights and circuitry
so all we need to do is take
this screwdriver
ah damn it some of the housing here you
just gotta unscrew that
and place three triple a batteries
okay so one battery goes into this side
and two battery stacks on top of each
other so
screw it back in place
and
back into
the tesseract
they are like
holes
on which it catches on so it's not gonna
be a loose piece per se
but i gotta love the texture inside
though wow
that is cool
so perfect on the outside and then you
got all the textures on the inside it's
crazy
it fits together like so
knock it around
oh am i supposed to turn it on so i
turn it off just turns off
you can double tap it
it is a bright bulb though so it just
lights up like that and then the
lighting effect is just pretty much a
fade
[Music]
pretty much it also got one two three
four five six
led bulbs right there
what if you shake it can you do anything
no that's pretty much it dude
how's it
light it up and there you go
oh and there's no wiggle room by the way
you don't you don't carry it like you
know
falling apart inside it's pretty snug in
so that's pretty cool
but there you go here's the tesseract
let's turn off the lights
and see how bright this goes
in the naked eye
think you guys can see it too it's
softly breathing which is pretty cool we
couldn't see that just now with the
lights on
but this is
okay yeah i gotta admit this is actually
pretty cool
there's a glue on my face
does it
anyone can tell me in the comments
whether this is the right size of the
tesseract is this too scale to let me
know in the comments
there you have it the marble legends
series test rack from
loki
it's a cube what else is that saying
lighting effects pretty good the build
quality it's sturdy it's not just like a
cheap plastic which you drop and it will
break i don't think it will happen nor
should you purposely let it happen it's
not overly bright but it's bright enough
that you can use it as a nightlight if
you wanted to
which i think is cool
so we've got the eye of the model we've
got the
tesseract maybe we'll see more of the
infinity stones
coming soon
who knows
does it justify a 90 dollar price tank i
don't know
they have to add this
and these go up to like what 30 bucks
but anyway do stick around today out of
this video so you can check out the ayah
ragamoto which
oh yeah
see what i mean
much better
but to each his own
let us know down in the comments if you
guys are going to get the tesseract for
yourselves do you think
it justifies that price tag then do you
think you get it anyway
let us know
until then yeah check out our vagabondo
video
right here
[Music]
you